[gibberish]
(Gets tased)
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to
Three
Scary
Games.
SPOOKY THINGS!
SPOOKY THING!
Anyway, so this is starting off with "Apartment 3906"
Uh, this is supposed to be a short horror game
that's about an apartment
which is not an uncommon setting that I have seen before.
"Click to take pictures"
That's also something I have seen before.
But-
We'll see how you do it.
*mark noises*
Look for and gather evidence.
Evidence of WHAT?
WAS THERE A MURDER?
DID SOMEBODY DIE?
Alright-
*camera flashes*
HoooOOOOOO
now that's what I call a P I C T U R E
HABOWSKI!
Ahhhh.....~
uh-WOAH
Is that blood?
Or are those just paintings?
Nah, those are just paintings.
Thought it was blood.
What?
Oh, that's the chair.
Oh.
I- I saw a shadow moving in the darkness
so I assumed it was something trying to kill me.
Don't know why I assumed THAT
That's a weird thing to assume in this place--
OH
Beach week?
*triggers something*
*spoop*
Wha-uh OK?
*something clatters in the dark*
OH.
ˢ ʰ ⁱ ᵗ
What did I do? Why did the candles go away?
This is some F L A S H
Poof!
Evidence of some kind of dinner?
Doesn't seem to be any kind of... oven?? In this kitchen?
No stovetop? No nothin'?
They must have just a George Foreman
they bust out every once in a while?
How about you? HABOWSKI!
A dirty clock... (¬_¬)
HAWBOSKI!
No? What about that clown?
That clown don't look too good!
I don't trust no clown. (Good choice, Mark)
Nope, that clown fine.
OH, GOD NO!
Wait, this...
That looks familiar. That's
from another game isn't it?
Uh, I don't know, I don't remember.
Can I go through doors?
No, I'M STUCK.
Did something change?
Like, something changed, right?
I took a picture of that and then the candles moved,
so I'm assuming that something changed.
*flash*
H E L L O?
In the friiiii-dge.
I'm hungey!
Can I-- no? *DENIED*
Alright, so now I'm just a little confused.
What does it want me to do?
There's nothing I can use.
There's just- just a room.
Oo-kaay!
This a little ODD.
I'm at a bit of a loss.
But... not the worst thing ever.
I'm just assuming that I gotta take the picture of the right thing?
There's gotta be something in here it wants me to take a picture of
and it's probably a little bit finicky about what that is.
This ain't Fatal Frame
where it's gonna judge me on the composition of the picture
but probably is like--
Oh.
W H A T
Ohh I was-- I even looked--
Aw, God, this is-- okay, this looks bad on me,
wOOH
[paper tearing]
Oh Shit!
So the reticle turns gr-
*footsteps in the darkness*
G R E E N
When there's something of worth... to be shat (shot).
Well that's new. Oh!
Why, uh...
why this?
"Three Murdered, Killer Still At Large"
I think I've read this paper before (Have you?)
*spook sound*
*groan of impending doom*
WAAAIT A MINUTE
FOUR MURDERED?
"Still At?"
Oh, no.
*gasp, spook sounds*
Heyyy...
Hey bud-dy!
HEy
Hey buddy, hey buddy, heyy
Hey, who is there?
Huh, who's there?
Oh yeah, okay, alright.
OOHH, yOu (YeA mE)
Okay, alright
Well, I'm ready for whatever you're gonna dish out to me *camera sounds, ominous clicking*
[still ominous] Uh oh.
Alright.
*glass shatters, Mark gasp*
WHO did it *slam*
Oh shit, who did it?
*slam*
Ohh, that's not good. [scared Markimoo]
Hey, wait a minute. [BU MP!]
[more urgent] Hey wait a minute!
[louder slam]
HEY WAIT A MInute!
Ohh it's dark over here! [slam]
Oh no :(
O H [Jumps]
OOOOkay, it's just shadows
[demon slamming]
It's just horrible shadows
HEY-yy
What?
Who did it?
You
YEAH? OHH!
OH OKAY!
Alright - WAAIT A MINUTE
HEY WAAIT A MINUTE!
[footsteps]
HEEEY!
[rapid thudding]
Hey?
Is that a knocking?
Is that a knock-knock-knock on the cellar door?
Is that one of those rrrrap pap paps??
oh.
uh oh [rapid thudding]
Something went awry. (Away)
This don't seem quite The Same.
Alright. [louder rapid thudding] Oh!
It is!
It's a rrra-pa-pa! [thudding continues]
Hello!
[even more thudding]
DiGiorno? 🍕
[loud sound] [Camera clicks]
[whisper] it's not delivery 0-0
ooh, shit
Ooh, that's not a good sOUND!!
[loud static] NOOOOO! [static]
[spook music]
Oh! I'm dead! [laughs]
[weird, wheezing laugh]
Well, there you have it!
I'm dead!
Great!
I love that!
And actually that was pretty good, that was pretty good.
For, uh,
MY own stupidity,
got me lost there, but that was just MY fault,
not the game's fault.
Definitely MY FAULT.
So, I will take the blame for that.
100%, that is entirely my fault.
but, pretty deese. (decent)
Alright, so this game
[camera charging up noise]
Oooh?
Okay, is my flash charged up?
"Daisy's Farm" [ominous music]
Uh oh.
Alright, Daisy.
[threatening music]
Ooh!
Daisy!
[threatening music continues]
Oh my, Daisy.
Your music is so... [music intensifying]
ominous...I like it.
[horrible squishy sound]
AH! I don't like that. 😨
Oh, god I don't like that.
[reading] "It's dusk on Daisy's Farm
and the Mindfruit is ready for harvest."
Oh yeah!
The  M I N D F R U I T.
We all know it, we all love it
This is what it looks like! (Looks like an orange)
Huh? Pretty good right?
Okay, anyway.
"Collect the ripe, orange M i n d f r u i t
as quickly as you can.
Move too slow and you'll be food for the crows!" :)
"Once the M i n d f r u i t  Bar has appeared,
you'll only have a few seconds to pick it before it spoils."
"Even if one Mindfruit spoils, death will follow--"
[[confused silence]]
O H !!!
Perfect!
Perfect! I was hoping for that!
I have multiple questions.
I'm very confused.
Okay, why seconds, why does it spoil so fast,
why does Death follow?
Alright, whatever, let's do this.
Oh, Daisy!
Oh.
Uh, Daisy?
Oh, Daisy! :)
Oh, DAAAISY!!!!!!! [screams]😱
Daisy: Come closer.
Daisy: I don't bite.
[unintelligible]
Daisy: Although, maybe I would.
Daisy: If you untied me.
[crow cawing]
[Daisy giggling]
Well, I mean, you still got that whole mouth sewn-
[slimy noise]
OOoh🙀
Daisy: We'll just have to find out~
[disgust]
Uggh.
Daisy: Won't we?
No, I don't wanna find out. Actually I - I don't
Why do I...
Do I gotta..harvest 10 fast?
Daisy: Picking M i n d f r u i t ?
[Daisy laughs]
Daisy: Naughty boy.
Daisy: Better grab the next ones - FAST!
Okay!
Ugh, why you gotta say "naughty boy"?
This is like some perverted, horror version of Farmville.
Ugh.
Why are the noises so weird??
Why are YOU so weird??
So, who tied you up there?
Is that just a hobby of yours?
To be..tied up like that? Okay, alright.
You know what, its fine.
Don't answer me.
You were real talkative before, I don't even know how I got here.
Daisy: [cooingly] Well done.
Daisy: Are you proud of yourself?
I sure am, yes I am! :D
Uh - oh okay, alright, you're not gonna
tell me to go drop off...[crow cawing]
[crow cawing]
Alright, Daisy, okay good talk!
Thanks, yeah thank you, I'll just
I'll put them in the bucket, yeah, I'll just [plops]
There we go!
Ploppit-
Daisy: Better hurry. Harvest the  M i n d f r u i t  quickly,
WAH???
Daisy: or feel my WRATH.
Feel your wrath?
Is that a threat or a promise?? ;)
Ya frickin weirdo.
Okay! Oh, no, wait, hang on.
Woo, wait! Hang on.
Wait, what?
There were two!
Is there a fake...is there a fake  M i n d f r u i t ?
Is there like a power fruit?
Is this like the Infinity Fruits?
Am I tryna collect all the colors of the fruits?
Somethin about tasting the rainbow? (Taste it motherfucka)
I'm not 100% sure what's happening, Daisy.
Daisy: [scoffs] Too easy.
Well- well says you!
You're tied up! You're just watching me!
That crows gonna peck your eyes out if you even have eyes.
'Scuse me, sorry Daisy.
Didn't mean to get that close to ya.
Weee! (Giggity giggity ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
Why are you - why do you have a burlap sack for a head?
Why are you like SackBoy but only the head portion?
Okay, alright, anyway, bye Daisy.
Mm, sure, whatever.
OOOOOH!!!!
Daisy: Do you feel a worm in your brain too?
Wait a minute!
Hey, THAT'S-
That's not... a good -
Oooh shit
Ah, oo oo
[more effort sounds]
Why is this the way that it is?
[disgruntled sound]
AAAAAGH
Okay, well, it, okay alright
I think I could just run around it,
why do I gotta run through it?
That's the question of the day.
Oh!
Perfectly easy!
The trick is to NOT run through the spinning blades of death!
Yeah, that's a smart move on my part.
I'm a smart guy! [Sure are, Mark!]
Full of smart...
t h i n g s...
in my head
Daisy, I don't like your tater totters :(
ooOOh Shit
I think that there's something left to be desired.
I think, um...
yeah, it's, it's not good
[waiting in silence]
Oh! I'm done okay, thanks Daisy for the heads up!
Also, what's that in the distance over there?
That's kinda weird.
Who knows what that is!
Why is there a cellar door here? [knocking]
Okay, nevermind.
Y'know what
What??
Voice Behind Door: You got spunk, young'un.
Voice Behind Door: Just, don't ask what happened to the farmers.
Voice Behind Door: NEVER ask about the farmers.
Voice Behind Door: And get outta here! [slamming]
What??
"Never ask about the farmer"?
Now I really wanna ask about the farmer.
Hey Daisy, what happened to the farmer?
Daisy: The crows are watching.
Daisy: Don't disappoint them!
What?
The crows are watching?
Why - why are they watching??
[concern]
[Squish]
Easy peasy!
[squishy squoosh]
Oh, where is it, where is it?
I don't see it!
Oh SHIT
NOOo!
GIVE IT TO MEEE! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I got it :)
[Confused silence]
I got it! Oh wait, I got it, okay.
The crows, did they see that?
Huh?
Did you see it Daisy? Pretty cool, right?😎
[distress sound]
Daisy: Now for a challenge!
Wha-uhhh?
Why? :(
Okay..OOOOO
Alright, well, not that bad.
[squishy]
Woah, what, huh? Wait, wait.
WoAHH
Hey! WOAH WOAH WOAH
[ominous music] [squishes]
What's with that double harvest thing?
Ooo, shit. Where is it?
GIVE IT TO ME!!
Where is it? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh, it's not there.
Oh, okay, alright.
Ah shit! No! SHIT! NO!
OH GOD
GIVE IT TO ME ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
AAH
ugh.
Daisy: No! You cheated!
I cheated?
I clearly didn't cheat!
Didn't you hear the screams of terror?
And also what are those things?
What's with those?
I dunno what those are about.
Ah- wah-- oh wait a minute
Daisy: Slice and dice, baby!
Daisy: SLICE AND DICE!
I - I don't like...slice and dice.
[Squishes]
[concerned gasp] I thought that was gonna get me!
Ok- ooh shit- you're making it easy!
[MORE SQUISHES]
[Mark scream]
Oh! No!
Hey! Wait! Come on now!
I didn't - that wasn't fair.
That wasn't fair! Hang on, wait.
Wait.
[absolute disbelief] Noooo..
Whaa?
Are you kidding me?
Alright, anyway, so uh..
Yeah, I'm not gonna do THAT again.
Because, uh, number one,
I don't feel like it.
And number two,
I don't feel like it. [laughs]
But not bad, like, it's an interesting game concept.
Like, the whole collecting and avoid death.
It kinda reminds me of uh, Killing Floor.
Y'know, that just kinda random thing, but
Yeah thanks Daisy! It was good meetin' ya!
Daisy, you're kinda...weird...and- and
horribly disturbing and you don't really have toes
But, y'know, I don't want to point out anyone's personal problems, so.
And, to be honest, the whole toe thing is the least of your concerns at this juncture, so.
I'mma get out of here,
you have good time,
I'll see you...in the next farm!
Uh,
Later.
That was interesting.
Tha- uh- number 1 that was interesting
uh, number 2:
that was interesting
Different concept, but I- I felt no
-compulsion to go back to the beginning and play through it again.
So we're gonna move on!
Alright, so this one is called "Paranoid"
The game's still under development
What are the controls?
WALK and RUN
[Duh! face]
Well it's just that easy!
Alright, let's do this c'mon.
I'm ready for this.
ooh...
Hello ?
"Chapter one: Hooome"...
Well- OH it's an elevator!
That makes a lot more sense
I thought it was just a weird metal box
hello?
Hellooo?
Hm. Hello?
oh ?
That wasn't in the control list!
Oh
Nice? I guess?
Alright... okay...
I see you
Aw sweet!
I keep my sodies
OUTside of the fridge
I'm such a REBEL
I'm such a BADASS
I'm gonna renovate the entire industry!
Hello?
oh nuthin...
Okay that's just a weird... window [laughs]
Is that my patio? I'm guessing? But-
-It doesn't seem like that
Hello!
Hi- uh oh
Oh no!
I broke up-- or
I've been broke up with
Hello?
wELL ya know I'm not that tired!
-To be perfectly honest
I don't think I need sleep that badly!
I don't think I need a shower this badly either.
Alright... well that's weird...
Alright, let's just go into the bedroom
See if I-- [LOUD SQUEAK] [GASP]
AAWW YOU SACK OF SHIT
No, not really I can't see nothing it was
real dark in here.
Hello?
Alright well I guess that's a whole lot of nothing then...
Hey is there anybody in here that I need to see?
[soft vibrating noise]
Oh...
Okay? Hm!
[[weird distorted scratchy noise, possibly talking]]
Sorry I can't hear you, you're breaking
up
How many of you guys at home think that this is a bad thing,
or this is a friend desperately trying to get in touch with us
and warn us that something bad is going on?
Or just trying to get in touch with us!
Trying to catch up!
Finally reaching out, phone doesn't work.
Such a tragedy
Alright well, I'm- I'm g- [POUND] AGH
WAIT WHAT HAPPENED? [Pounding continues]
[Pounding] WHAT HAPPENED???
o-OH O-OH NO "THIS IS NOT YOUR HOME"
[pounding stops]
Well okay, alright, well that's just a--
Then that's just a misunderstanding!
Oh, I should have known!
My "t" isn't right-side up in this place!
That was my bad.
Thanks for pointing out the error of my ways [chuckles]
Alright well...
[Loud Pound] BWAH!
"Get" [POUND]
Oh!
That didn't make sense until I--
Wait, hang on a second o.0
Oh... o.0
Hai [laughs]
Hello-
Oh, okay alright! Well see ya!
GeT OuT! THIS IS NOT YOUR HOME
Get the heck out,
you piece o' poopy!
I'm assuming I need to follow?
Is that my buddy?
Lady?
Oh no
Lady he's dead
[click] Oh okay he's back.
Ah! That's weird, did I just make a goof?
Did I goof it?
Did I make the big goof?
I'd like to go home I'd like to contact the--
Wait a minute... hang on a second...
[inhales]
Hmmmmmmmm?
[Puts on a weird voice] Well, you know something don't feel right about this move
A a a h h h
That don't seem too normal!
I'm uh, pretty sure that ain't something that's uhHhHhHhH-
-supposed to happen so uh,
let's uh, just see what we got--
[spOOK] wAAHH FUCK
[spooky ambience]
I   H A T E   Y O U
Okay alright. >:(
Yeah alright, oh I got a bone to pick--
Aww frick well there--
-what the hecking
What?
[ambience grows more intense]
[car tires screeching]
[car crash sound] [Well, someone's dead]
[spooky ambience continues]
Ohhh...
Oh...
Wait what?
Wait what the heck??
Oh! :O
What--DAAAH [screams]
I fell I fell I fell!! this was a bad move-- I--
[ambience continues]
Alright let's go back in, ah?
Alright I'll be right back, I'll just rush back...
That was very dumb of me, I will up-- I will admit... real dumb
That was very dumb
I should-- I should've been better about that
Okay I'll be right back
Alright well there you are! I got a bone to pick with you!
Come back here you!
Oh you think you're gonna open an elevator for me? No...
Lemme in... LEMME IN!!!
Alright if you won't let me in, I'll have to let myself in!
[Pound] Whoa! [Pound] Oh okay!
Whoa!!!
Ooooh!!
Whoa
[gasp] Hi 0.o Oh ok...
Hm.
Somethin' uh--
[creepy fucking voice]: ᴡʜʏ (ᴅᴏ) ʏᴏᴜ ᴡᴀɴᴛ ᴛᴏ ғᴏʀɢᴇᴛ?
ᴄᴀɴ'ᴛ ʏᴏᴜ sᴇᴇ ᴛʜᴇ ᴛʀᴜᴛʜ?
ʀᴇᴀʟɪᴛʏ...
ɪs ғᴀᴋᴇ.
ᴛʜᴇ ᴏɴʟʏ ᴡᴀʏ ɪs ᴅᴇᴀᴛʜ.
sʜᴇ ʜᴀᴜɴᴛs ʏᴏᴜ.
ʏᴏᴜ ᴄᴀɴ'ᴛ ᴇsᴄᴀᴘᴇ...
ᴍᴇ.
O k a y!
Wasn't trying to!
Just trying to find my apartment I keep finding the wrong one!
Ooh, what do we got here?
Oh...
Alright...
bright... it's briiiiight
Oh it's my apartment!
Oh, let's go to bed!
Nope wait-- can't- can't go to bed!
Alright, no going to bed, huh?
Alright well tippity-top down the stairy-wheresies
That's a light ?
I think that's import--
Oh no what have I done??
This is a really cool aesthetic!
I really like the visual of this place!
It's kind of funkalicious!
I don't know if funkalicious is the appropriate term to use but to me it's funkalicious.
Thanks for putting a dot in the center of my screen [laughs]
Uh huh...
Nice windows.
Oh!
Hey!!
It's you!!
How are you doing?
Hey come over here!
Well I got a bone to pick with you, you jump scared me last time and I didn't much too like it,
so I need to go talk to y--
Oh don't turn your weird face on me and do that,
that's just uh...
That's uncomfortable.
That seems lovely
Oh! this is...
This is an   a e s t h e t i c!
Beautiful in here, it's beautiful
It's very beautiful very...
very very beautiful x4
very beautiful x5
Very beautiful x6 ooh
very beautiful x7 very...
very illustriously beautiful x8
very very delightfully beautiful x9
beautiful x10
it's it's beautiful x11 in fact it's-
It's gloriously beautiful x12
Hello
Hi chair! how you doing? Hey long time no see!
Why aren't you-- why are you out of Amnesia™
Hello table! How you doing? Hey good seein' you!
Okay it's a maze, um...
I don't know where the hell I'm supposed to go.
Nice triangle
If the objective was to get me lost you really succeeded!
I am....
I'm lost :/
Help!
Help! [chuckles]
Hello--?
OH
Youuuuu lighty!
Goddamn you!
Oh a, a door!
Um...
Hi? Okay I have no idea what you're talking about
I-- I don't speak because you didn't let
me speak!
[INHALE]
I was trying to say hi and then nothing happened, so I'm just gonna leave and, and goodbye!
Alright, see you, goodbye! Goodbye...
Hey look, bright light! Hey the door route was over here the whole time??
You could've--
uh oh
Oh no!!! It's a SLOOOONDERMAN (Slenderman) game!!
It's turned into...
A Sloondy...
Sloondy's Castle
Oh I can-- I can see it all now the-- the
A E S T H E T I C
It's so pleasantly perfect!
With his tie and his glorious demeanor in the original originator of chromatic aberration... [ooh big words]
Okay, so I just gotta go back
Well good thing I know the layout of
this place so particularly!
I ain't never gonna be lost!
I'm never gonna find a key either...
Oh!
Key! I found one!
Alright, one two...
buckle my shoe... hello
That explains why there were all the nooks and the crannies.
Ah... oh maybe it only spawns one at a time cuz I thought I was here before but I didn't see that one...
Uh oh, I've been at this so long the music just cut out and looped around again!
Hey, Lixian can you cut out this music and replace it with something a little more festive,
you know something really lighten up the moods,
because I think- I think- I think that's what we're missing here!
It's just it's too glum!
This place really needs like an "oompa" sound to it
[polka music plays]
Yeah yeah that's the--
Tha- yeah that's good that makes me feel better
Ah I'm just-
I'm just moonwalking out of here
Just cuz I'm like I "Ah"
I realize I actually don't have to participate in this weird game
of LIGHTIES
I'm just seeing if um,
if they hid the key at the beginning of the level which they did NOT
Answered that question...
Glad I did!
(I'm not glad I did...)
Alright put the music back
[polka music comes back faster]
[music stops]
Um, if I was a key...
and I was the last key I had to get, I would be in the room where that guy is,
and he's now dead.
That seems like something this game would pull.
I go back here,
I go like "I can't find the fifth key D:" but he's dead!--
Aww, he's not dead.
I mean-- yay! You're not dead!
I guess yeah I shouldn't be happy-- or-th- sad that you're not dead
So- I-g- I sh- I should probably be happy...
Alright anyway good talk
Love our talks...
wHeRe iS tHiS kEy?!
Ah God...
Wah !!!
Woeeeeeyy!! :D
Gotcha!
Alright, okay! Gotem!
I dunno how I'm gonna fit these keys into a door made of light,
but, you know I'm gonna try guess.
Hope nothing bad happens
Hey you dead now??
Now that got all the keys? Hey buddy, I'm celebratin'!
I got the keys!
Alright, you don't care, you're just taking a perpetual pill-- Oh hey
That's a cool aesthetic!!
That's so cool!
That's such a cool ATHAESTHETIC
That's so cool, look at that LOOK AT THAT!!
Look at that!
That's thumbnail-worthy that's so cool!
No I love triangles
[Creepy fucking voice]: ᴛʜɪs... ɪs ᴛʜᴇ ʙᴇɢɪɴɴɪɴɢ, ᴍɪᴄʜᴀᴇʟ.
ᴛʜɪs ɪs ᴛʜᴇ ʙᴇɢɪɴɴɪɴɢ.
[mockingly] Thith IS THE BEGINNINGGG!
Alright okay alright
whoa...
Hey wait a minute no you said it was the beginning
You lied this is the end!
You LIED!!
YOU LIED TO ME!!!
YOU LIED!!
YOU'RE A LIAR! [laughing]
You're a liar, you lied to me 😢
Alright so that was "Paranoid"
Started out really good and strong
I like the- the- the modified hallways and all I love that shit I love when the environments change I love just like-
-throwing things off like that.
Um, however the end was--
There's a lot of times when horror games do often devolve into:
"FIND 'X' NUMBER OF 'X' TO PROGRESS"
And it, it is a bit hampering
There- there are times when it's good and it's helpful like if there's a story reason behind it,
but there's no story reason for a bright white wall to be like, "gO FiNd tHeSe KeYs!"
Um, but that's not saying it was bad, but still,
Not bad like it did scare me, a couple times!
So that was...
Three
scary
G A M E S
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If you want to see more scary games look in the description!
Click right down there "Read more" or above the description,
Look for a playlist that has all the scary games
I've ever played
over the past
s e v e n
y e a r s.
So check it out there,
and if you want me to play more games and you got an idea of what they are let me know down in the comments below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always I will see you in the next video!
Buh-bye!!!
[outro song]